hello I'm Alistair Murray I'm the water
manager for the Invercargill City
Council you may have heard about the
council wanted to upgrade its water
treatment plant we're going to do that
it's a major project with 11 and a half
million dollars at the end of it will
have a much safer water freer of the
harmful organisms of giardia and
cryptosporidium and also a much better
performance for taste and odor removal
this is where it starts we're here at
diritti river this is the intake to it
there's your et River out in the
background today we're going to take you
through the treatment plant and show you
we were going to upgrade the process
this is the first stage of treatment
that's where we settle out the suspended
clay and silt fines from the raw water
we do that chemically we could of course
have a large lake and allow it to occur
naturally but that would take far too
long so we have to use chemicals we will
upgrade that process with new
instrumentation will be much more
efficient we also drop out all of the
bacterial load at the stage as well now
we're at the second stage of treatment
versus filtration we have 12 filter
cells knowingly one of our operators of
one of them our own staff including no
meat will be engaged to remove the old
media nozzles and put the new filter
media and nozzle in here we have an
example of the old-style media sand on
the top gravel on the bottom and the old
nozzles very heavy media very difficult
to keep clean the new media coal media
much finer aperture on the nozzles much
better water coming out of these type of
filters now we're in the general area
where most of these new upgrade works
that will give us the major improvements
in a water will occur will have a new
backwash tank will have a new
ultraviolet hydrogen peroxide plant for
taste and odor removal much more
efficient than the old powder activated
carbon system associated with it a
granular activated carbon filtration
plant here we are this is 2016 vintage
ranks on water treatment water
we'll come back to you in the new year
2017 with a much better quality water
free of that summertime muddy taste and
odor smell cheers